talk about your
relationship with nipsey man i'm nipsy
somebody who you know i was close with
since about 09
um one of the greats uh you're
on arguably one of the best songs on
victory lap
um you know he i i know i'd always see
all the xo guys around nip like any time
he would do an activation i'd see nav
over there
talk about child's relationship man uh
when i first came to l.a man nip was
somebody that was just like just like
like instantly you know a friend it was
crazy like
um just like two three weeks and then
knowing that i felt like i knew him for
like 10 years
right he was that kind of guy for sure
yeah he would and like he would pull up
to the house
uh you know he would come through with
slow mm-hmm shout out to slow slow
was living with me at the time and um
um studio city
and nipple pull up man and just like it
wasn't even about like working it was he
wouldn't even want to
you know not like he wouldn't want to
but he wouldn't even play his records
he'd just be like
let me hear what you're working on i
thought that was so dope because you
know every rapper is getting everybody
wants to play you their [ __ ] and they're
like yo where's the ox you know that's
the ox he was always just like now let
me
i want to hear what you're working on
like he was just genuinely like
you know always always interested and
and and whatever was going on it was it
was vice versa you know like
i was always a fan in it uh it wasn't
just from
when we met before we met i was a fan of
them right right so
i made sure i let that be known you know
throughout the whole course of us
working together and and being friends
and all that
i let people know the the level this guy
was on was different you know what i'm
saying like it was
it was something special to see somebody
like that come around
and double up like was that something
that was pretty much
like done and then you you you added
your part or like how did that
how did how did you end up on that song
because it's an like i said one of the
best songs on
on the project for sure um man they
brought me the song and were like
uh basically you know nip been wanting
to work with you on something whatever
like he doesn't know that we're giving
you this so just you know do your thing
and then we're just gonna
basically like you know play it for him
and be like yo you know what i mean yeah
and um yeah it was nuts bro like i
remember
i did this there's way more of that song
that never made it to the song
you know did you have a verse on it ever
i had a verse on the song
it was funny because that was when i
first got that [ __ ] victory lap
on spotify that was the first song i
went to and i was so disappointed that
you didn't rap on
i mean you did your thing about it but i
was like i was like oh
belly and nip that part that that uh
nip ended up using throughout the song
that was that was like a my outro after
my verse
so that was like you know that's how i
kind of ended my verse
and um but it was it was it was long as
[ __ ] man
i'm sorry it's a long song currently
that's what i'm saying the song was
about to be like seven minutes and 45
seconds right
all right i never i was never like damn
why why aren't you keeping you know i
was just
happy to be part of it that project was
a classic
to me the first time i heard it i was
like this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
a masterpiece you know in our world
that's a masterpiece right there
100 man yeah i think we get one of those
albums like every few years
where we're like yo this will live
forever you know what i'm saying
and i think i think your album might be
one of those man you know what i'm
saying
man i might be in the discussion i hope
so bro like
you know i make this [ __ ] between four
walls i think i told you this when you
came
you know because you were one of the
first people that came through and
listened to the full length
yeah mastered versions of the songs you
know